or vraiment le rideau monsieur le
préposé aux rideaux voilages et ça y est
c'est fait
ne cassez pas les micros monsieur dans
un voulez vous aller 8 5 3 c'est parti
décontracté
venant de la rivière
pierre posée sur sa tentative est sorti
sans trop tôt les
silhouettes
geipan des couleurs claires on est dans
l'oeil des
caméras paul est clair si vous êtes déjà
au
milieu
avec des cochons cpi vous et je suis
amoureux
de musique ancienne depuis changerait
clairière et fadil euros pedro de
l'angola
les verts libéraux
défini moi je l'espère depuis moitié
cher de téléphone en colère
on a des abonnés mobiles et moi j'espère
avoir
fait connaissance blessé à la cuisse
contre
les classes
le nom de la rivière qui taquinent hier
est caché dans les fougères jeudi
regarder passer le long de la rivière
renault tv est conscient mais si je
gagnais
non
tu vois
alors pedro dans ses mains serrées on
allait bientôt contourner c'est dans les
gênes cassant le rythme face à 10 ans en
photo les s'est envolé partager les
prêts dans ses bras canadien pour
prêcher cochons et couvées messieurs
grand talent qu'elle vient de prouver